where do you carry around a germ that
can kill people what one of these guys
sleep with a corpse oh well every hour
on the hour it'll just be like baby now
has to join his hand writing a book is
not about just writing the book the hard
part now is with this promotion I came
up with a Time Square billboard because
I assume you're gonna have a Time Square
billboard okay assume anything but go
ahead I have a concept for it that I
brought in to show you can I oh yeah hey
we've got the visual aids oh boy well
you actually like try and have an open
mind about this just immediately [ __ ] on
it Robin can you see your ideas Wow okay
you know when you see it when you see it
at first you might think oh what's so
great about that shall we - okay imagine
this like 20 floors high in Times Square
all right okay so this is what its gonna
look like this is a billboard it's a
billboard it's imagine it's like you're
lying in bed naked you got to see this
something you're jerking off and you're
smiling you're smiling are you familiar
it's a bet no I swear to God
how many billboards have you seen in
Times Square I'm a guy jerking off are
you [ __ ] happy
implied jerking off because you can't
see your hand in the book you're not
gonna put that up and [ __ ] how are you
I was excited about the point is like
now you're this like evolved family so I
put the picture of your like cat Walter
you got Beth watching you jerking off
and then let your blind cat is in bed
with you while you're jerking off you
have the book
covering your junk so no one's offended
and you have a big smile okay I had an
interaction with you in here yeah I was
so impressed I was like you know this
[ __ ] guy is counted yes I don't know
if you're for real or not the same thing
you did with the Superbowl commercial
like yes a billboard of my book would be
fabulous in Times Square now think about
it I want to reach the people yes just
listen to me I want to reach people who
maybe don't realize this is a really
good book in my opinion like something
really really really meaty and really
good to read this is evolution yeah I'm
trying to reach people who maybe are
turned off to me they see a picture me
in bed Jirga is provided that even in
Times Square the guy who owns the
billboard is willing to put a guy
jerking off in the bet implied more than
what you're looking at yes might change
your mind
like do you remember how Dave Letterman
used to like squirt water on people as
they walk this is the surprise people
are in Times Square yes like families
and and every hour on the hour it'll
just be like Oh
[Laughter]
at least you saved the best part I'm
with my med on this that's [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] turns into this MIT has like
facial recognition technology so now
you're being a guy coming on come
it's just shaving cream yeah but but you
don't understand coming out of his day
his implied dick book that's covering
your job come every hour in times okay
Ronnie if you want to believe him at one
point Ronnie said that he's leaving at
the end of this contract either way is
that right I didn't realize that was
where we were with Ronnie Ronnie sixty
nine he'll be 71 yeah but he's got more
energy the guys feel [ __ ] like a young
man I mean maybe stop doing many good
work a little longer up I'm interviewing
new security people know short people to
hedges yeah I'm interviewing somebody
who is about four foot eleven in a
seventy-four years old
ronny was guarding me the other day
we're walking to go this guy can barely
walk how is he guarded are you still
sticking by that Ronnie like I deserve
some notice I mean I am starting indeed
I told your death is that I mean I felt
like it was sort of vague still I wanted
to finish that official is it official
that you are done at the end of my
contract as far as I know yes
what do you mean as far as you know who
else would know no I say as far as they
know that's they don't you don't want my
plan that my plan is to replace you at
the end of that time yes Wow Wow is
right
why no I just can't believe it is there
a time that you just want to lay back
and what do you have to do every bad
pain pain pain but the [ __ ] is your
problem over there is a season you're
going to sleep also hey is that what you
want to do with your life I mean you you
get a lot of fun out of his shows no I
enjoy I love it here no quitter and then
you get on the air and you bow though
off and everything you know I know I
know he's gonna be miserable why do you
think I'll be miserable because if we're
still here and you're not you're gonna
hate it but I won't be here I'm gonna
move away where are you going I'm
planning to move to Vegas if you leave
who's gonna protect us from the poison
bagel Gary's doughnuts yeah it's time to
hang up the [ __ ] rings oh yeah at some
point your [ __ ] gonna start not working
all that great it probably won't yeah
I'm assuming you're probably just gonna
have to go down on Stephanie every night
I think that what he's doing is he's
conserving himself for that oh why why
do you think that Ronnie will turn into
a lesbian because I'll be able to do I
think that because you've burning the
candle at both ends here no no putting
the candle in my ass
yes al you're on the air in
Massachusetts he's out of his [ __ ]
tree why am I out of my tree dude I
thought this whole women I would cut my
left that off the drive a guy like
Howard around dude I've been here 34
years okay kids where are you
dude I'm going nowhere dude that's the
whole plan to go nowhere oh you go
[ __ ] driving Massachusetts and you're
complaining I'm not complaining is
Stephanie looking forward to seeing you
all day now it should be at work she'll
be working what are you gonna do I'll be
spending time with my dildos
you don't read you don't have any
hobbies you know what he's gonna do yeah
he's gonna get his car and drive around
I know he might as well drive me let's
see what can I do today I know I'll
Drive to Henderson in back yeah Fred
what are you gonna do if I retire I'm
gonna go into subway with my Ronnie
puppet right paraphernalia in front of
JD he apparently doesn't know how to
work a lighter is that right oh you
should have you should have JD light
they join themselves gary described the
scene to me right now this for bond
table that are loaded with weed there's
joints all over the place
lighters all over the place I mean it's
it's a pothead seven Wow the budtender
has already pre rolled two joints yes
she's gonna come over right now and
she's gonna hand one to JD business all
right so JD now has to join his hand
yeah and the lighter in his left hand as
if it's the first time he's ever held a
lighter I can't he can't light it this
is my Tim he doesn't know how to use a
lighter can I give you a little hint or
just let him keep no let's see him
Landon what do you what did you problem
you put the lighter in one hand in your
light JD what do you later yes and when
you push down on that thing you got to
hold the red button down go slow no JD
you're really uncoordinated over
try a Mac have you ever laid a candle uh
yeah but I use those like big things and
what the clicker okay all right all
right take it easy and don't get all
defeated I want to get out of here just
now I was done with the lighter remember
JD didn't know how to boil water I'm
being serious and we had to teach him
how to do that so immature so in his
right hand is the joint right and in his
left hand as a lighter that he can work
JD are you ready so you want to put the
joint in your mouth when you're gonna
light it so you inhale while you're
lighting
inhale while I'm lighting just taking a
big hit and blew it out like a champ
I'll do another one ready why do I I
don't know what's going on there but I
have the feeling that he's not going
like that the first two didn't take that
was a quality hit how does that feel JD
anything yeah see Ronnie took a hit
right Ronnie you took a hit right I
don't think you did you coughed to get
off
[Laughter]
Ron you're right Ronnie's gone did you
did you take a hit I don't like this
dude is no swallowing all the way there
you go
hold it Turner izing for turnin izing
Sal's dad came here from Italy at age 14
right yeah dropped out of high school at
age 15 went into the pizza business
mm-hmm in fact Sal's dad claims he
invented pizza toppings right yes and
the round Pizza the round pizza and
pizza toppings yeah he no kidding he
invented the calzone
yes yeah it should I set this up to this
new this is you know I've said I think
we've learned everything about Sal that
there is to know about his marriage
about his father about everything
recently Sal learned he has two sisters
he never knew about like how recently
like just a couple of days ago yeah
pretty close yeah well we've known that
Sal has had siblings stepping up listen
to stories right yeah they're the third
and fourth siblings that have been
discovered from outside the family yes
well as a special Father's Day treat we
have Sal's dad live via satellite from
his home if you look over Robyn on the
guest couch monitor you'll be able to
see sows that
[Music]
but what I mean what do you say wait to
see this on not gray-haired mr. Mario
Merola you know them at all what can we
say we're shocked by the amount of
sexual activity without a rubber that
you had very much very much I find very
sad I pray for the forgiveness from all
the Saints but I promise so that's all
there's definitely not a 396 or more
kids I stopped looking ok alright and in
so many children can even track their
names so many fathers day a very busy
day I have a sol Claudia Patricio Sergio
Barrera Gianna Gianna Gianna Alessandro
bolaño Donna beneath saw Marco Marco
kneebar Biglia Guevara Pavarotti Lamarr
Brent cysteine Fiorello Fiorina Fiorano
Giancarlo Carlo you know all the kids
names it's unbelievable I'm shocked that
you do I know half I know 200 feel any
remorse do you feel bad about what you
did but I hated these DNA websites I
find out who run the website I take a
loaf of bread and I beat the [ __ ] out
it's an Italian sword huh you know maybe
I don't want to be radical here but
maybe you should get your balls clipped
I mean it's outrageous right yeah you're
more active than a sperm donor but I
pray I pray to the same so that my wife
forgive me I pray this Anthony's ain't
been easier and I'm a faithful man now
and no more sneak around I know you're a
good man now and I promise
oh hold on a second I get a phone call
you hold on okay oh no you know this is
a Tony come back lock I tell my wife
about a window it's okay
okay I got the money in that darling
sorry that's that's it a telemarketers I
keep going mr. Govan alley
it sounded to me like maybe you were up
to your old ways and shenanigans right
after you just cried to the whole family
for the forgiveness aleut ly absolutely
well I hope you have a happy Father's
Day mr. Govan Ali of course it'd be a
great day my windows look very dirty I
gotta go get the Windex right oh go
ahead okay there was hundreds of
children when the door opened you
claimed those are not your children Eric
do you think my book is flying off the
shelves because of this right now
oh absolutely shelves are empty what was
that noise Oh Eric is that you yeah what
does it hurt you to get down and your
knees not really and why do you make
that noise when he has to put effort
into something Howard right now in this
singlet well he's in a giant scale all
right Eric you're in there they're
strapping you in and now let's begin JD
you're gonna load the books
yes very good JD you're gonna do a stack
of 10 at a time yeah all right let's
keep track everyone so Howard here comes
the first step first act you got to see
this one nothing Eric didn't lift at all
that's 10 bucks second stack 20 bucks
and Eric hasn't but the scale is still
tipped to the floor third stack 30 bucks
and Eric hasn't budged off of the floor
Jadey bringing forth JD's workout for
snacks that's 40 you feel like you're
moving at all no all right fist stack
fit stack that's 50 bucks I think I'm in
big trouble
I think Fred's looking like a genius
stack number 660 books and and Eric has
not lifted off the ground Jesus Christ
was 75 so I'm eliminated here here comes
80 80 let's see if that 80 books have
you moved at all Eric no this is our
first level we can only get 90 books on
the first level all right
so 90 books are on the scale man why did
what happen I saw a movie I'm not sure
here we go 100 books our tiny bit and
move to a tiny bit stack number 11 110
volts is coming up right now stay common
110 copies of Howard Stern comes again
close to me now here comes back number
12 Howard he is off the floor here comes
stack number 13 this would be a hundred
thirty books out one time out of it oh
my god you got to watch this
oh now we're gonna go to single books
alright hundred thirty you're going
you're you weren't right but you might
win okay here comes one thirty one one
that lights gonna turn green when it
gets even look for the middle light 132
here comes one thirty three turn comes
again let me take a look at the
predictions here afraid you were way
over at 400 bucks sorry
let's see somebody I guess Herrick wins
oh we did so Robin you win at 120
because you are under you settled on 150
so you are old it's all in fun and and
Eric thank you for helping us promote
Howard Stern come see amazing wow look
at you sitting there like a boot so you
really into radial Hall of Fame I am I
am a nerd I think agreed but I think it
should have the same level or respect
with the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame at I
think his next project as he wants Fred
to get it I want Fred in and Gary in and
the Howard Stern Show I want Fred in
absolutely
I want Fred out of here and in the radio
seriously you should be in the Hall of
Fame humble look how unique what the
unique thing that Fred does nobody else
in radio does what go ahead again just
no one wants it nobody wants his job so
remind people with president me
he adds a layer to this show that's
really incredible
sound effects I love him Fred should be
in the radio Hall of Fame 100% I'll I
carry the other that's the boy played
clip 18 JD personality and he speaks
well on the air he's been a great
seducer for a lot of years interesting
stories for the show you don't have to
convince me
I'll tell you about the time when I was
very young and I actually was gonna
maybe go to the pet supply business
store and I work for them I would sell
the wee-wee pads and they said you know
if we ever open a second store on Long
Island we would like you to orchestrate
so Fred starts texting me like two weeks
ago I gotta take care I've never read
your book I'm gonna read your book and
they're sending me all these texts about
heartfelt things in the book and then I
realize he's reading the book so he has
material to make fun of its goal
research Gary puppet if you were guy if
you really got into the radio Hall
affair would you have an idea of what
you would say okay we'll talk about my
Thanksgiving dinner oh yeah without
mother see we my mom would cook this
Thanksgiving dinners he would make the
you know the sweet potatoes with with
marshmallows and the turkey and the
spaghetti and the meatballs but on a
side table was like a little kid's table
she had this little card table and she
would put the artichokes if anyone
deserves to but you know I want to
nominate to the radio all those that
right there JD Harmon I'm not kidding
you just to hear his speech but I mean
seriously you're good on the air I mean
you know I mean good bad you know
whatever I mean just take Dean joke over
president in there I'm definitely not
afraid you're in my Hall of Fame Fred
would you be upset if Gary gets in
before you no no no very material would
love that
oh you Carrie would be the guy it would
mean nothing to Fred but it's crowded
because I'm bringing Marion Jackson
because I'm gonna bring Mary and you
know dog
mommy cuz movie is my best friend
Bernie's dead oh oh if you were here
right now you'd really enjoy this I'm
going to heavy metal concerts and orgies
what are you doing with your life
certainly you must believe that Brent
did go to it you got to hear this story
I believe listen I believe the attempts
are always made sure was out of steam
man let me ask you you're the liar let
me ask you about this friend you short
[ __ ] I'm not lying about that no you're
not you're short policy
five seven five five to ten please you
want to talk about 210 not not at all
buddy I'm down to 190 you can hear the
button straining of it I'm down to 190
sou orgy weren't you in the hot tub nude
yeah I mean way better nude the new fat
boy let's get back to your origin yeah
you're in here's you doubt me because
you don't do anything really interesting
and orgies what are you doing with your
life this is like the so you guys
walking what time in night does this
thing start a dish no it's probably
we're on 11/11 or exactly yeah I could
never be
I would have been asleep three hours
earlier early-bird swinging joke so you
get there and are people walking around
in their clothing or they knew at first
everybody's clothes right like you know
women are in sexy outfits how would you
assess the women where they tens were
they fives with it what were they I
would say it's five or six to attend no
there was no nobody there that was
terrible and you're saying there were
tens there yeah Oh all day not as 100 or
out of ten how did the men look on a
scale of one to ten are there tens there
as well yeah there's yeah there are
where are you on that yeah I'm just
curious because I'm actually in really
good shape right now
go ahead I probably bought a 7 right now
choose a 2 but hey look man I I had was
perfectly comfortable staying where
they're male tens there yeah after the
rules the read is that when you guys rip
off your clothing and get in the tub
naked so after the rules are read we go
to there's a little landing outside and
we smoked a joint with this other couple
right and then we said you know we're
gonna go get in the hot tub so we got in
the hot tub there were did you take off
all your clothes yeah that's one of the
rules is everybody that gets in the hot
tub has to be nude and you're not
self-conscious I mean you just go right
in Nate no no I'm not he's a seven no no
I feel I feel actually really good these
days about my body especially I feel
better being nude than actually wearing
clothes ladies
what would your man say is your biggest
turn-on your biggest turn-on what turns
you on most Stephanie and Caitlyn I got
this one
go ahead when he rubs my but when he
rubs your butt that is your biggest
turn-on go ahead Ronnie me he said me he
says when you look at him
holy [ __ ] deal I mean Ronnie what's
going on here what do you mean I
answered the way I felt like it I mean
you think you're so hot that when she
looks at you
dad-dad she's gonna get turned on if she
doesn't then there's a [ __ ] problem
well come on G all right he doesn't
understand the class no I understand it
no you do say that it Kaitlyn see if you
can get one point
what would you man say is your biggest
turn-on your biggest turn-on I like when
he just starts giving me a head he's
just like a Saturday morning and he kind
of starts to wake me up a little bit
with head when he goes down on you when
you just wakes you up with you going
down yes right brain come on put me in
any sexual situation do you believe the
[ __ ] egos on these two guys Kaitlyn
you're laughing wine because it's absurd
and it's so general like how many things
could fall into that category ladies
you're doing a beautiful job of
answering these questions I do not fault
you one but both of these guys said
basically they turn you on I mean it's
crazy
Carrie is leading the charge because he
wants to win but he thinks that that
answer was collect act in mind that
turns her on
she said when he goes down on her of
course it is but that's clean [ __ ]
Bay
any sexual situation you [ __ ]
alright I'll go to the judge John is
that a match and he's the Jetport
[ __ ] imagine who hired
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think this was Milan idea cuz he was
behind all of this so here's what we did
we swabbed a couple of guys who work
here you know the usual suspects we use
sterile swabs and vials we did a sneak
attack no one had a chance to wash their
hands or use Purell so who did we
surprise we surprise Richard who's
disgusting Sal who's disgusting JD is
disgusting
Benji's disgusting Brent I always
thought was pretty clean so we figured
we'd swab him cuz everyone knows Brent
like a zit control and Gary - I figured
he be very clean so we swab him anyway
because everybody knows Baba Booey yeah
and we swab three areas we swab their
hands we swab their little workstation
and we took one personal item like their
cell phone and swabs it okay the vials
then are put on ice they're shipped
overnight to a lab in Kingsport
Tennessee why Kingsport because they
were tested by dr. Steve the same guy
you hear on weird medicine on Sirius XM
channel 103 and dr. Steve is like the
real deal so I'll bring the six guys in
now and I'll read you the results okay
and I don't know what you're gonna say
you've seen the results I do not know
all of the results I know Gary's very
nervous about this that's the word I got
you're very nervous about it I'm always
nervous about anything I'm involved
whether it's an IQ test or anything but
I'm I'm pretty confident I know that I'm
the only person I believe in this group
I do clean my desk maybe once a month
with Clorox and I clean my phone once a
month once a month you know what are you
saying so you should wipe down your desk
daily you know you do yes I don't
believe that I really don't want to
month's disgust I don't believe that you
wipe your desk down every day and Howard
he eats that peanut butter right out of
the jar and he leaves that smelly saliva
spoon on his desk I use plastic utensils
douchebag I bet that will be the most
hygienic and then Richards second most
well after these results you may never
return to work Robin you might want to
work outside of the studio I have a
question for everybody here does
everybody
take a shower every morning before they
come s I do I take mine at night yes I
do yeah who says no no Richard Richard
does everyone expect Richard to be the
most disgusting no I think he's gonna be
one of the most clean why do you say
that cuz I know his habits he washes his
hands like crazy so I do it's time to
get some results so I'll eliminate three
people up top okay okay right away
I'm gonna name right now the three
people who are not the germiest staffers
but are still very disgusting all right
the three of them that are the least
germy
but still disgusting Brent least Wow
Benji and Sal Brent you had moderate
traces of Basilius serious on your hand
and workstation moderate Benji your
personal item your backpack had moderate
levels of it there were low levels on
your workstation and shockingly your
hands were very clean oh thank you okay
Sal you had bacterium serious prevalence
everywhere okay relevant on all three
areas we tested you had high levels of
it on your cell phone and your
workstation and small levels of it on
your hand but you are covered thank you
in diarrhea causing bacteria how have
you you you behind glass I am now gonna
reveal out of Gary Richard and JD JD
you're rocking back and forth like a
horse you okay you'll see it'll say okay
I am apparently
the person this is just disgusting
hurry we get to it the person with more
fecal bacteria on their hand then on
Richards [ __ ] is Richard that makes
sense that makes sense the dusting wash
your [ __ ] hand do I do
no you don't I do how do you wash your
hand
I sing happy birthday while I'm washing
I put soap on that much Beagle matter on
your oh you know what maybe it was I
wonder if I spread my [ __ ] to get the
first swab and then got poop on my hair
that's the last that was the last thing
yeah there goes that theory you know
what it might be maybe from my phone I
look at my your theory is that your
phone could have more fecal bacteria
than a human [ __ ] it could it's
insane I think I don't know why I still
had my hands and [ __ ] the person out of
you three was the only subject we tested
to be carrying a serious bacteria called
micro caucus luteus it was found on one
of the person's workstation that way and
you will be named our germiest staffer
Wow
this this serious bacteria is so
terrifying it normally colonizes in the
mouth the mucus in the upper respiratory
tract it can even cause septic shock it
can be deadly under the right
circumstances
[Music]
is so bad at washing your hands that
you're carrying around potentially
deadly bacteria how could that be
could you be bad at washing your hands
that morning or you have to be so bad at
washing them everywhere in it do I have
every single answer I don't but you get
it JD do you think you are the one who
has deadly bacteria I immediately goes
to the worst thing so I'm immediately
determinist person here do you think
Raya and everything else JD do you think
potentially be the one who's the
cleanest no they kept talking about my
workstation is it out there was the only
thing that came up black I don't know
yet I really do not know the results
honest to god I don't
I agree with him it's not a good look to
have your q-tip turned black yeah Gary
do you think you could potentially be
the one with the deadly bacteria mounted
germiest I'm gonna go out on a limb cuz
if I lose I'm gonna look like an [ __ ]
I in my mind I'm the clean guy uh-huh
Richard never mind uh I think my work
station is filthy but I'm I wash my
hands can I bet $20 that's scary with
the deadly especially we want to take
action I can't imagine it's Garen well
you gave away something you said it
starts in the mouth and the respiratory
system he's always Flemmi and he
generally has Howard Clemmy Clemmy
sounds repertory I was trying to use
science you know how that works right
right never worked more wrong Sal hey
Maura JD and Gary it comes down to the
two of you
one of you is so disgusting you are the
only one we tested carrying the
potentially deadly bacteria called
Micrococcus laticious does anyone know
how you get it but why would one get it
on their hands it can be airborne it can
be something you pick up it attaches
itself to your respiratory tract a lot
of fun and then if you're like sneezing
or whatever gary is that you I mean I
don't think so but I don't think so JD
is that you I'm sure I can see any of it
happen my merrily comes from not washing
your hands yeah all the time I want to
be what I don't believe that's me I wash
my hands I can't believe all right here
we go I hope listen I showered that
morning I don't believe I hardly use
this bathroom here so I didn't have any
whatever well then go on the test those
in line okay dr. C dr. Reed everyone's a
[ __ ] expert around all right yeah I
know
JD you are the guy who didn't wash the
sheet I'm well aware thank you I have to
think it was you but let's see shirt are
you opening the envelope Sal says he's
got a lot of phlegm that's right
you still think it's Gary's yeah
absolutely where do you carry around a
German to kill people I mean one of
these guys sleep with a corpse there we
go I'm sorry if it's you JD or Garrett I
know I'm sorry
all right I'm sorry
the person who is so disgusting that
they're even more disgusting them
Richard is
[Music]
right now Wow Wow tell me again what
this disease is that carries on his
hands Micrococcus luteus it's very rare
the plague and if you have a lowered
immune system brilliance was the only
person we found lots of like shared
bacteria among people somehow this was
the only person walking around the
office who's spreading this around his
workplace and that's the workplace where
we found it who do you think it is Brent
I think it's JD how think SATs Gary you
think it's JD Benji who do you think it
is Gary I think you're a clean person
but it's definitely you yeah Richard who
do you think I think it's JD from the
way you were laughs and how Robin who do
you think it is I mean I gotta go with
the track record JD Fred who's the one
carrying around a germ so vile that can
kill us hate to pile on JD the answer is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Howard Stern Show